well there's gas prices we know those
are up groceries they cost more rent is
rising as well it just kind of seems
like there's no relief in sight yeah
it's just unrelenting bianca holmen live
this morning with how to navigate the
rising cost of living bianca good
morning to
you good morning so it seems as if rent
prices are at an all-time high and it
doesn't help that some people are just
now getting back to work after about a
year and a half of being unemployed so
we looked into this we did some research
we looked on rent.com and that's a
platform that a lot of people use to
find their next home a one bedroom
on the website was around 12-hundred
dollars to as much as 17-hundred dollars
for high-end luxury units but just a
year ago in february of 2021 an average
one bedroom was around 1100 bucks we
spoke with a local real estate agent on
the valley trends
we are also seeing more of an increase
over the last month than ever before
with rising interest rates those that
may be looking to purchase homes may no
longer be in the market therefore more
renters are now even in the market than
ever before not just coming from
california or from new york or other
states keep in mind that interest rates
play a huge part in rentals
there are three other important things
that renters should keep in mind
property owners will they look for a
good credit score at least 650 or better
number two do you make three times your
rent and number three what's the status
of your rental history now coming up in
the next half hour we're going to have
some more tips on how to navigate this
rental market right now because again
these prices they are not forgiving
bianca holman live local now